over the last
five years i've had 22
different clients and or employees
try and repurpose you know our licensing
material into their own business and um
i wanted to make this video to talk
about how to handle that
as you inevitably grow in business this
is going to happen to you so it's a
matter of when not if
and what i think have been some of the
best strategies that i've that i've used
to deal with them so by the way fyi my
name's alex from rosie i own
acquisition.com we do about 85 million a
year in revenue i have nothing to sell
you
so today i want to talk about uh kind of
the the backlash against competition and
copycats and things like that so
the biggest problem that most
entrepreneurs deal with or at least that
i was dealing with uh each time
especially earlier on when this would
happen is that i took it as such a great
deep personal affront
as in it was a it was a true
um attack on my character i was like how
could you be this way i thought that
they were scum
um and all the many things and thoughts
that we you know would naturally go
through
but i had a mentor early on in my life
and she shared something with me that
i've always it's always stuck with me
and she said
you will become astonishingly good at
predicting the behavior of others if you
always assume they will act in their own
best interest
and
that has been incredibly telling and so
instead of listening to what people say
and uh and believing them if you just
simply can think what is in this
person's own best interest independent
of myself or anything that i am you know
basically take yourself out of the
equation and think from their
perspective you will become
astonishingly good at predicting what
people are going to do right
and so the idea if you want to get
people to do what you want them to do is
that you must align what is in their
best interest and what is in your best
interest together and if you can do that
and accomplish that effectively then you
will be able to harness people's selfish
nature towards a common goal which is
ultimately what a lot of business really
is right so
back to the story
22 different people have tried to take
our stuff repurpose our stuff and it's
not just taking and repurposing it it's
typically also
uh
additionally
them talking [ __ ] right about you um
and usually soliciting uh other
employees or current clients of yours to
go with them right
and so that then creates even more anger
because it feels like someone's taking
your stuff etc but this is what i can
tell you has happened
in the few instances
that i did earlier on my career where i
focused a ton of time and effort on
these people
i even one time dramatically changed my
business model in response to
somebody who was trying to solicit my
best clients and my current clients to
start a business adjacent to me
um the only thing that happened was that
i just hurt my own business
and the reality is
the vast majority of my customers had no
idea any of this was happening at all it
was all happening in my own head and i
was magnifying it way out of
blowing it out way out of proportion
right and so
if you're in this situation
these are some of the things that i
think through or that i think with
to help myself feel better about it
number one
they need me i do not need them i am the
source
of the thing that they are trying to
copy and therefore they will always be a
subset of me which means they cannot be
bigger than me if the source of
everything they have is me right if
their source of customers is my customer
base if the source of their of their
business model is my business model they
need me i do not need them
right right so that's number one
number two the type of person who
operates in this way
admits that they are a follower and not
a leader all right which means that they
cannot lead you it's a different way of
saying the first one but i think it's
worth mentioning right
number three
the type of person who operates in this
way will always operate from a place of
scarcity right they will always try and
hoard and they will always be focused on
you
and not their customers all right so
where their focus goes right where your
attention goes uh shoot what is it where
attention goes money flows that's one of
my one of my money sayings um
if someone is doing that right then they
are purposely telling the marketplace
that you
are the focus not them and not their
customers all right and so
the thing to do and so these are the
actions to take if you're in one of
these situations
if they get loud
you get louder about yourself
you get louder about your solutions you
get louder about your purpose about your
mission you never acknowledge them
ever
coke never acknowledges pepsi the
classic never acknowledges the inferior
there's no point you gain nothing the
only thing that is gained is what they
what they should hope that you do
is that you give them credit
right and as soon as you speak their
name into existence they become more
elevated and then they become on your
level and so you can never acknowledge
that they even exist
all right
but if they are allowed
then your
course of action is to become louder
about your message
and so if you need something to motivate
you use it to motivate you to market
harder to sell harder and the saying
that i like to use in our company is
beat them in the field all right if
people are talking smack in the stands
beat him in the field all right look at
the scoreboard
that's all we care about all right
and so these are some of the things that
over time i've kind of accumulated in my
little toolkit of you know mental
toolkit of of how to deal with the
haters and the people who copycat and
steelers and all that kind of stuff is
to understand that they need me i don't
need them
that when they focus on me they put more
attention my way that the only thing
that i can do in response is to get
louder about my thing
never acknowledge them
right and finally just remember that the
person who always gives the most to your
customers wins
period and the founder of hubspot said
something that i think is really cool
and powerful he said you don't have a
customer until somebody has offered them
a cheaper version of your solution and
they have chosen not to take it
that is when you have a customer and so
i think that's really telling is that if
you if you're so confident in the value
provide then you shouldn't be worried
about it if you are worried about this
person then double down on the value
that you're providing to your customers
and then it will help you sleep better
channel the nervous energy or the angry
energy that you have not at the
competitor but target into the value
that you're gonna provide to your
customers all right so i'm not saying
you know i'm some saint i'm saying i've
done 22. i've got like
i was counting with my my gm the other
day we're talking about every single
time somebody has tried to attack what
is ours right has tried to take what is
yours and uh saying from yellowstone the
show that i like is that
anything if you if you want anything if
you have anything worth having
people are going to try and take it from
you right the only way to have something
that no one will ever take from you is
to have something that no one wants
and if you want something that other
people will have
if you have something other people will
want then you should expect that people
will try and take it from you and you
should take the fact that they are
trying to take it from you as a sign of
success that what you were doing is the
right thing
because they are trying to take it from
me because it's an indicator that what
you have is desirable all right and
that's the game and the more desirable
the state that you have is the more
people will try and take it from you and
so having these mental things these
mental tools in your tool belt
is very useful as an entrepreneur and
i'll leave you with one final thing
i think that when i look back on my life
when i'm 80 or 90 years old
i will be ashamed of things that i did
and actions that i took out of malice
and so i think that the truest
guide that we can use for what actions
we should take in response to others
is what values do i want my life to
exude what values do i want my actions
to stand for and be in alignment with
and if you don't think that inaction
will be in alignment with the values
that you would have when you're 80 or 90
years old and you look back on the
situation
then don't do it
right or do the action that is in
alignment with those values and a lot of
times the sad part about taking the high
path is that when you win because right
now i'm 22 for 22 in terms of people
that i have defeated
who have tried to to take what is ours
you don't actually get
you don't get a victory lap you don't
get a victory dance because when people
lose to you
you can't go stand on their corpse and
teabag them like a like a uh like a
video game right it doesn't work that
way in the real world
they disappear with a whimper they fade
into not in into obscurance or into
obscurity
they fade into non-existence
that's what ends up happening
and when asked about why when they tell
their own story
they'll just say they decided to change
their mind and didn't want to pursue it
anymore because of xyz reason that they
will cite about the industry and never
take uh ownership for why they actually
sucked
and uh if you're one of those 22 people
and you're watching this video um
i remember you but i will never
acknowledge your existence
um and so i uh i say that because
because when you win it's not that
fulfilling
because it's it's very rare that you
actually get into a hot battle with
somebody it's all happening in your mind
and most people just
don't have the skills to compete with
you if you have a business
and they'll eventually just disappear
and it just sucks to have to deal with
it and
the thing is is when they disappear
you'll have forgotten they exist to
begin with and so it's not like you get
an envelope in the mail that says the
person you know
waves the white flag they'll just move
on with their lives and so will you
until eventually you forget they exist
and uh and so yeah so that's the
unfulfilling uh path of the victor but
the thing you do get to have is you get
the scoreboard and you get the business
and you get the clients and you get the
impact and that is really the only
reward for continuing to act in the way
that is in alignment with values and
providing more value to your customers
is that you'll just continue to win in
the long haul and everyone else will
just shrink in comparison to you so
anyways bossy nation i make these videos
because a lot of people broke and i
would be one of them i don't want you to
take a stupid action as a result of a
competitor or ex-employee or an
ex-client trying to siphon your clients
it happens it's part of business the
fact that they're doing it shows you
that you're on the right path just don't
do anything that 85 year old you
wouldn't be proud of all right lots of
love keep being awesome i'll catch you
guys next video bye